all right so you're familiar with the
original Star Wars trilogy as well as
Jar Jar Binks and those three prequels
but you may have even seen the Star Wars
Holiday Special
look at lumpy so where does rogue one a
Star Wars story fit into all of this I'm
gonna tell you let's pick up at Episode
let's call it three and three quarters
with Star Wars rebels it takes place in
the latter part of that 19 year gap
between Revenge of the Sith and a new
hope the show lays the foundation of the
Rebel Alliance focusing on a team
similar to rogue ones outmatched heroes
they put up a good fight against the
Empire but like a bunch of Padawans
versus emo Anakin they don't stand a
chance see the Empire had much bigger
plans like building a super weapon Space
Station capable of wiping out entire
planets the Death Star had been under
construction since the Clone Wars but it
was missing a very important feature
that whole planet destroying laser park
and in retrospect they could have spent
a little more time designing those
exhaust points
[Music]
which brings us up to the events of
rogue ones prequel novel catalyst the
book focuses on jennarose father in
super talented scientist Galen as well
as Orson Critic and up-and-coming
imperial lieutenant
Galen specialty was generating power
through the use of Kyber crystals these
crystals are kind of like the dura cells
for lightsabers now imagine what you
could build if you had a whole bunch of
these things so good old critic
eager to put a cherry on top of the
Death Star sundae brings Galen to
Khorasan to work on a sustainable energy
source wink wink
what Galen doesn't know he's actually
helping critic developed the weapons
tech for the space station being the
great guy that he is critic supplies
Galen with piles of Kyber crystals but
unbeknownst to Galen these were all
taken from the lightsabers of dead jedi
total dick move right
when Galen finds out he's not too happy
he and his family escaped from Khorasan
with the help of sagar era who's the
leader of a resistance group called the
partisans so when we catch up with SAW
and rogue one we can assume that Ginn
already considers him a close friend
speaking of jinn she's all grown up in
quite a rebellious badass with a
particular grudge against the Empire
she's also the perfect person to lead a
mission to steal the Death Star's secret
plans from Episode four we already know
that her team is successful in getting
these plans to the Alliance but we don't
know who will make it out alive do you
have any theories on how the film will
end let us know in the comments and for
all your film TV and comic book needs
keep it here on gamespot universe